I want to follow up on a story from 2015
okay
the setup for this is I've given my view
about the prosecution of former Nazis
before and I've been very clear that it
doesn't matter how old they are it
doesn't matter how long it's been since
the alleged crimes they committed during
World War two there is no statute of
limitations on prosecution from Nazi war
crimes
so you prosecute anybody you believe you
have strong evidence against and then if
they're convicted you can consider the
age or health situation of the person
convicted in sentencing this brings us
to Oskar graining who is now 96 years
old
we talked back into July of 2015 when
Oskar graining was charged and initially
convicted and he was convicted of being
an accessory to the murder of 300,000
Jews and was prosecuted in Germany he
ultimately was sentenced sentenced to
four years in prison and he appealed
that sentence on the basis that he is
not fit for prison prison that appeal
has been rejected and a doctor now says
graining is fit to go to prison assuming
that the prison has appropriate medical
care for him and speaking when he was
sentenced graining said no one should
have taken part in Auschwitz I know that
I sincerely regret not having lived up
to this realization earlier and more
consistently I am very ja sorry but
there's a lot more in terms of the
specifics of this case which is that he
seemed to know and sort of relish all of
the money as the bookkeeper of Auschwitz
that he was handling and of course the
counter is well yeah he enjoyed getting
and handling that money but it was money
that had already been appropriated by
the Third Reich or whatever we could
kind of go back and forth all the time
right but generally speaking this is the
process any of us could argue a
particular person shouldn't be in prison
but the process is if there's no statute
of limitations that has expired you
prosecute once you have a verdict if
it's a guilty verdict you sentence and
then in sentencing you can consider age
or health in sentencing and a doctor has
said this man is fit
what do you think that well I mean the
sad thing is to begin with that this guy
won in a sense that he was able to live
his whole life as a free man and you
know maybe he was stressed out for a
good amount of that time knowing that
sure possibly be caught one day but only
until he's in his 90s as he actually get
caught up that that's where I think you
have to start and then you get to a
point where the guy is facing only a
four year prison sentence which
certainly doesn't add up to the crimes
that he committed it should be obviously
the rest of his life which for years
maybe at this point but how different
would his life be you know he's in
prison versus under house arrest because
you'd have to imagine at 96 years old I
don't know what healthy is yeah I don't
know how he active he is but I'd imagine
that his day-to-day life isn't going to
be much different whether he's at his
home or in prison my thought was that
house arrest would be okay here but I
think you struck on one of the most
important arguments which is by saying
someone is too old to be sentenced if
they are found fit for prison which
Ostra braining was you're basically
saying by virtue of having avoided
justice for most of their lives they now
are going to be rewarded by not serving
time in prison
this is someone who arguably should have
been imprisoned their entire life for
his role in the deaths of 300,000 Jews
at Auschwitz why would we reward him
because he has avoided punishment for
the majority of his life I fundamentally
don't agree with that but bottom line
when we look at the specifics of this
individual 96 year old man I think house
arrest would be okay
and how do you get only four years for
this I mean I know maybe they even I
guess it because he was the bookkeeper
yeah he wasn't I don't know doing worse
things still accessory to 300,000 death
I know I know
so bottom line I think that the process
here was the exact right process you
prosecute you convict you sentence and
then you hear appeals for sentencing
based on age and a doctor was involved
in made the determination send me your
thoughts what do you think is
appropriate for Oscar graining